hello everyone I'm pleased to announce
my new tour for
2024 beginning in early February and
running through June Tammy and I an
assortment of special guests are going
to visit 51 cities in the US you can
find out more information about this on
my website
jordanbpeterson.com as well as accessing
all relevant ticketing information I'm
going to use the tour to walk through
some of the ideas I've been working on
my forthcoming book out November 2024 we
who wrestle with God I'm looking forward
to this I'm thrilled to be able to do it
again and I'll be pleased to see all of
you again soon
bye-bye in the US only 11 States produce
more energy than they consume 39 States
consume more than they produce Jordan
and buy a lot and the big ones New York
and California they're importing their
energy well that's great as long as you
can but ask Germany how that went when
the Russian gas stopped it didn't go
well we have to start to um conflate
these things in what I lovingly call the
radical middle and that middle is
between energy the economy and the
[Music]
environment hello everyone I'm talking
today with Dr Scott Tinker uh I met
Scott at the art conference Alliance for
responsible citizenship in London at the
end of October where he gave a very
well-received talk on the Nexus between
energy energy and the environment and
it's been the most popular talk on the
ark website on
YouTube um racking up about 1.2 million
views as of today and so I felt for a
variety of reasons that it would be
worth delving into Scott's thought and
his back ground in more detail I've had
a number of people on the podcast who've
talked about the energy environment
relationship particularly as it pertains
to climate which is obviously a
determining element when you're plotting
forward an energy strategy we talk a lot
about the relationship between energy
and the rectification of absolute
privation there's a lot of people in the
world are still living hand to mouth you
might say and a huge part of the reason
for that is that they don't have access
to clean reliable plentiful inexpensive
energy in whatever form and are reduced
to doing things like burning dung or or
wood if they're fortunate the problem
with that is that poor people there's
many problems with that but one of the
problems is that poor people living hand
to mouth don't take a long-term view of
such niceties let's say as environmental
sustainability which doesn't occupy the
Forefront of your thinking if you're
trying to figure out how to scr around
in the dirt so your children don't
starve like today and so there is
evidence that working to eradicate
absolute privation around the world with
the provision of more inexpensive energy
for example would
simultaneously be the best possible
Pathway to genuine environmental
sustainability as when people become
more wealthy or even a little bit
wealthy they start thinking over a long
term and are more concerned with the
viability of the environment for example
or even able to conceptualize such a
thing and so we delve into that in great
length trying to flesh out what a more
multi-dimensional view of human
flourishing and environmental
sustainability might be so Scott the
last time we saw each other was in
London at the end of October and you did
a speech there which has been
extraordinarily well received um on the
arc website Alliance for respons
citizenship your speech on energy in the
environment is the most popular speech
now I think Constantine kissen probably
has you in total views because his
speech has been distributed in other
locals and has kind of gone viral in
multiple places but it was very
interesting to me to see this happen
because well that sort of thing isn't
predictable I think there's probably 30
speeches up now and it wasn't obvious
that it would be a talk on energy and
environmental policy that would take the
spotlight obviously you did something
right I mean it's it's a very well done
talk technically you know it's it's very
accessible and you're very engaging and
so that certainly didn't hurt but why do
you
think first of all what did you think of
the art conference and also why do you
think that your speech struck a court
it's got about 1.2 million views as of
today
yeah yeah yeah that's good I like the
art conference and I appreciate the
invitation there really do I love the
diversity of the audience representing
Global thinkers that was nice and and
the broad depth uh Jordan of the
speakers themselves and the bread of the
topics I didn't expect some of the
things to be candid with you we we went
from Faith and family all the way
through to education and of course
energy the environment and and and
poetry and music it was phenomenal so
congratulations to you and the baroness
for putting together a
really excellent excellent engagement I
really enjoyed my time there so thanks
for that yeah it was fun it was fun we
figure we we we figure we missed one
major area that I think we're going to
rectify we didn't talk about virtual
identity and I think we're going to add
that as a category so that would include
discussions of digital currency for
example Etc and all the potential
nightmares that come along with with
that but it would also cover more
broadly you know increasingly we have a
virtual self and it isn't obvious at all
what rights that virtual self has or
even who owns it in some fundamental
sense and that's actually a major
problem and it's it's going to get much
worse so well we'll Rectify that with
the next conferences so why do you think
what is it about your speech do you
think that struck a court maybe you
could outline first of all what you
talked about but also provide some
insight into why you know people have
really taken it to heart yeah I just
have a really big family and I made them
all watch
it yeah you must have a very big
family look I've been speaking on these
topics for three decades and and it's
nice to see I think what's happening is
some of the extremes on both sides are
starting to come around toward that what
I call the radical middle and and think
about these things deeper
than simply black and white or good and
bad believer or denier kinds of
dialogues that we have been pushed on us
so I think that's striking a chord now
people are that I've been hearing from
from all over the world on that speech
actually writing from every corner
independently are saying thank you for
your objectivity your balance for not
trying to be you know flamboyant or shov
an opinion down our throat thank you for
the data and I do tend to show a lot of
data in my talks but I I spend time with
an anime made it so you can understand
what that data is saying by the end of a
particular slide or or theme if you will
so a lot of people like the data uh
young people at that conference by the
way came up to me very much and very
often and they said we so appreciate
your tone not telling us what we should
think or what to do but just offering
this kind of setting if you will of the
energy the environment and economy for
us to think on and that that may be
striking a chord now and I know you do
that too I really really appreciate your
efforts and others who were at that
conference to to get us thinking and I'm
I think it's just time to think so
perhaps that's why it's striking a cord
well you know one of the things we
noticed because as I said we've released
a fairly large number of speeches and of
course the viewership follows a classic
predo distribution with a small
percentage of the videos taking up the
vast majority of the views and one of
the things that we noticed very
significantly was that any speaker who
politicized the issue got no
views right so it was people who spoke
two ways they either spoke on first
principles so to they took a more
philosophical rather than a political
view and then more educational and so I
think you you you probably tilted more
towards the educational side although
there was a philosophical aspect in your
insistence that there are that you what
we're always attempting to do is balance
tradeoffs right and and there's a
there's a philosophical notion there
that there's no perfect solution and
that many other competing Goods have to
be taken into account when we're
trekking through something as complex as
the relationship between the energy and
the environment which is an impossibly
complex Nexus and so so it's so one of
the things we've also learned although
we kind of knew this beforehand but it's
really been driven home is that when we
invite speakers even if they're
political figures we're going to first
of all focus on political speakers who
can speak from first principles and do
something more educational and we're
going to inform all our speakers that
that's much more likely it's much more
in keeping with the ark Enterprise and
it's also much more likely to be
successful there's a political figure in
Canada Pierre POV who's now the leader
of the conservative party in Canada and
most likely to be the next prime
minister and he's become a real expert
user of social media and so he ran his
leadership campaign for the conservative
party completely outside the Legacy
Media giving virtually no interviews he
created all his own ads and he's done
something very interesting in the last
month he's produced two 17-minute
documentaries one on housing and one on
debt that they kind of look like PBS
documentaries you know they have that
flavor that back when PBS wasn't a
political Enterprise they have that
flavor and it it it seems to
me I've also found on my podcast that
more political speakers regardless of
their Fame tend to attract
disproportionately few views that's
interesting so I think that people well
I think people are really hungry for a
different approach to problems and one
that's in keeping with what you did
which is like a serious discussion of
the facts dispassionate presentation of
the facts at hand understanding they
have to be viewed through the Nexus of
like a
multi-dimensional value hierarchy trying
to negotiate those not claiming that the
experts know what pathway forward is
best I and the problem with that view is
that well just because you're an expert
on energy doesn't mean you know how to
balance energy expenditures with
education absolutely and much less
healthare and everything else that has
to be taken into account so okay so
let's go to your let's go to your
background yeah quick comment before you
before you go I speak in Canada a lot in
fact I'll be in Toronto next week uh
speaking to the National oh I'm there we
should we should have dinner oh well I'm
speaking to the national uh National
Bank of Canada uh at their energy
conference um and we're starting to
see we're starting to see that what you
just described is this this desire for
more for more depth and I think that
kind of sums it up well particularly
this younger generation of people and I
have a PBS talk show we're in recording
our fifth season and you're right it's a
little bit politically biased but it's
still the most trusted Network in the US
at least in terms of an attempt to be
and we we very much do that on our show
as well is look for the multiple
viewpoints and and I've say this very
often Jordan one owns the truth you know
we just seek it particularly in
science we scientists live a tortured
life of always questioning everything
over and over skepticism it's part of
Science and and that's where I think I
might have kicked off my speech I'm
recalling now there in London following
your lead there was a bunch on kind of
religion and Faith early on I think day
one and I I talked about that a little
bit that you could Define faith much
better than I can but you know it's it's
a process in which maybe there's there's
less doubt when in faith but science is
filled with doubt with without doubt we
have no science and I think I probably
said there you take away doubt from
science it becomes more of a religion
and that is a very dangerous path to
walk down I'll I'll comment a bit about
the issue of faith and Science and uh
then we'll turn to to to who you are so
everybody's clued in about your
expertise and and we'll talk more about
energy and environment so been thinking
this through a
lot you know when a scientist confronts
a data
set he does so or she does so with a
variety of AIMS in mind now one of the
things I saw increasingly happen in the
last decades that I was in Academia was
that science became both politicized and
subject to the demands of career now I'd
seen this with with every graduate
student for example there's always this
terrible
tension between going into the data set
with an orientation towards the truth
and going into the data set knowing full
well that if you don't extract out from
the numbers a
publishable uh statement that all of
your efforts are have been in vain and
your careers on the line and you know
that whenever you're doing statistical
analysis when you're conducting
scientific inquiry you're always
balancing that demand to falsify your
own cherished Notions even those upon
which your reputation are based and
to demonstrate to yourself that your
current experiment was a failure with
the opportunity and requirement to
follow the truth and so what I would say
constitutes the proper place of faith in
science and I actually think this is the
right way to think about it
metaphysically is that you have to
confront the data set with the
presumption that there is nothing better
that could happen to you than to find
out what it actually represents
regardless of the apparent cost to
short-term or even medium-term cost to
your career and even more than that to
believe that in the long run medium to
long run if you actually pursue the
truth in your statistical analysis even
though you may pay a short-term price in
disruption of your pet theories and you
know the failure of the odd experiment
your career is going to be much more
reliable and much broader and deeper as
it iterates across time that's called
learning we learn from our failures
right not from our successes well and
it's also predicated on the assumption
that that learning is possible that the
universe is rational and that if you
learn from your mistakes that the
consequence of that will be better for
everyone and those are the axioms of
faith I think that are part and parcel
of the scientific process not belief in
the overall validity of a given set of
facts which is more like a
totalitarianism yeah yeah no that's very
that's very interesting and I think
wellp put um it's the challenge
academics face and I have been one for
23 24 years now out of the industry for
17 is is the push push push as you
describe to get your research published
and journals are want to publish
failures they want to publish things
that move the science forward some kind
of a learning or success if you will and
it's unfortunate because everyone would
learn much more if we were to publish
the experimental designs we set up and
the failures in those and and I think as
a result of that we've stopped asking as
many why questions we see a lot of how
what where when which is interesting
they're interesting ing questions but
why is the toughest question of all why
in in life you know individual as well
as scientific why and that's really the
great challenge because you can only
typically prove things that don't answer
why not things that are the answer if
you will you knock down the
possibilities that don't address the
data set as you've described it and
that's very powerful as you go down that
road but it takes a long time and I
would like to see us come back to to
publishing more of the failed
experiments if you will I think we would
all learn greatly from that yeah well
there's obviously it's obviously time
for a technical revolution in scientific
publication because the whole process
has become it's absurd the fact that it
takes two years to publish something is
just you know it's just completely it's
given how easy it is to publish it's
just beyond comprehension the fact that
all that scientific research that's
taxpayer funded is locked behind to pay
wall the fact that the publishing
companies have a hammer lock on Library
Acquisitions and that the libraries are
what would you say Duty bound to
subsidize the Publishers like the whole
thing is just it's just a mess I can see
substack headed in a way that would
allow for rigorous science to be
published and and absolutely and
wouldn't that be neat I mean we talk
about peer review well you put your
science out there to the world and
there's plenty of peer review we hear
back all the time well you know we been
we've been thinking about doing that
technically too I mean one of the things
that should happen as well you could
imagine imagine a site where you could
publish your paper in the same format
that they're published
now a page summary for lay audience you
can identify your four peer reviewers
they publish their reviews on the paper
site they can take authorship of that
which would could be another CV
component because it wouldn't it be
lovely for people to get some credit
especially beginning scientists for
their peerreview work which is actual
real work if you do it properly and then
so and that could be done with some
degree of rapidity and then it it's up
to the marketplace to sort the papers in
terms of how much attention they attract
but that's also how it works in the
scientific publishing Enterprise anyways
and that could all be open access
absolutely I just can't see why that
like that's right in front of us and it
it at some point it's going to happen
and it takes peer review Out of the
Shadows
yes exactly exactly so yeah so I suspect
that we're very much we're very serious
about engaging in an Enterprise like
that excellent you know it depends where
it is in the priority stream but yes
that would be very nice so you have to
do yeah yeah yeah yeah right right
exactly although it's so important
because it really it it really it really
has become a problem and and it and that
that that fact that we've we only
publish successes when that's the wrong
way to describe success like if you
happen to stumble across a a more
profound truth because you set up your
experiment properly well more power to
you but if you set it up extremely well
and tested something of extreme interest
and it doesn't work out there's
absolutely no reason people shouldn't
know about that not least so they don't
do the same thing like multiple times
right so yeah you ask a ha question and
you have a hypothesis about that
question to test and throughout that
process whatever it may be your
hypothesis may be proven wrong and we
need to be able to show that that's why
we do science we're not all perfect
hypothesizes no no no not L we're
playing fast and loose with the data
yeah that's for sure so we shouldn't be
punishing the people who follow the
pathway of Truth so so tell us tell
everybody a little bit about your
background you've been dealing in in in
in the overlap space between energy and
the environment for decades so what what
are your why are you qualified to do
that how did that interest develop
well I'm actually a geologist by
training and have degrees in that um my
PhD uh from the University of Colorado
master from University of Michigan and
undergrad and degrees in business as
well so I've always been interested in
that overlap space because economics
drives so many things
and the environment is a natural piece
for geologists to think about I've spent
many nights in a tent in many places in
the world in the field we geologists go
into the field a lot and been fortunate
to visit over 60 countries deeply inside
of them from the the poorest amongst us
and I mean
literally step on a human being without
limbs in the dirt pour to probably some
of the wealthiest Among Us and and seen
all of that Jordan and I'm still only a
fraction of it but it's uh it's very
powerful I learn by uh that by sensing
things I people say describe India I
said you can smell
India you know you can taste India it's
you can't you can't those those are you
can't unsell or un taste' been there
particularly in the impoverished regions
and sure you see it and hear it the
noise is incredible but it it just
wakens up all the senses so that's as a
geologist um we are problem solvers we
deal with lots of imperfect data and
incomplete data I particularly study
that have studied the subsurface which
means you only get very small samples of
things and you have to do interpolation
and extrapolation in modeling and data
analysis and knowing that your answer
isn't right you're just trying to
constrain it around what the data tell
you and and then adapt and change as you
go so that's my background as a
scientist uh and a business person I
happen to have built and well not built
but over the last 24 years from 90
people to over 250 people the largest
research organization at UT Austin other
than a Navy funded one and we do energy
environmental and economic research all
over the world and half of our 250
person staff is are international not us
born at least and so very diverse and
fun
yesterday was my last day as director uh
after 24 years I fired myself so you
know at 64 years old it's time to let
other folks have that fun and and I've
got plenty to do into the future and
hopefully some things with you so that's
kind of my background uh filmmaker um I
host a PBS show I do radio broadcasts
and lots of speaking around the world
and have Through The Years got a
wonderful family a wife of 40 years now
now and four kids all grown and gone and
they're all data scientists
and and so they just keep teaching me
how little I
know and aren't they right so anyway
that's that's a little bit of my
background the 40 days leading up to
Easter lent starts on Ash Wednesday
that's February 14th this is a time of
intense prayer fasting in giving
Hallow's annual pray 40 challenge is one
of their most popular last year over
million people joined this year's pray
40 challenge focuses on surrender and
includes meditations on the powerful
book he leadth me this is a story about
a priest who became a prisoner and slave
in the Soviet Union during the Cold War
his story is one of Ultimate Surrender
and we are called to offer up our own
worries anxieties problems and lives to
God there will also be lent music lent
specific Bible stories and other lent in
prayers like The Seven Last Words of
Christ with with Jim cavel download the
app for free at hall.com Jordan you can
set prayer reminders and track your
progress along the way Hall is truly
transformative and will help you connect
with your faith on a deeper level so
what are you waiting for download the
hall app today at hall.com Jordan that's
hall.com
Jordan hall.com Jordan for an exclusive
3-month free trial of all 10,000 plus
prayers and
meditations all right so let me ask you
given that background let me ask you
some questions so I've been trying to
understand the energy
environment business Nexus for about
three decades I would say and trying to
use my experience in assessing
scientific literature and reading
scientific papers to get a sense
of the situation and so I have
a I have a provocative question maybe to
begin with so I came across the
data let me step one step back my
understanding initially was the idea
that global warming such as it is was
going to produce an expansion of the
world's deserts and
make the our
sphere more Aid and uninhabitable
and instead what I've seen since the
year 2000 in particular is the rapid
Greening of a very large geographical
area which I believe NASA has now
estimated at twice the size of the
continental US three times the size of
the Amazon jungle has greened since the
year
2000 and along with and the reason for
that is that carbon dioxide levels have
gone up and what that means is that
although there's been a certain arguable
degree of heating so to speak because of
that it's made it easier for plants to
breathe and when they can breathe easier
their breathing pores shrink in size
because they don't have to expose
themselves to so much surface area and
because of that they can conserve water
much more efficiently and because of
that they can grow in areas that would
have otherwise be too AIT and because of
that we're seeing a tremendous amount of
Greening not in places where there was
already plenty of water let's say but in
semi-arid areas so that the the deserts
like the Sahara particularly in the
South are now shrinking and so part of
me thinks when I look at the data from a
bird's eye view let's say that the most
striking ecological fact of the last 20
years is the radical increase in Green
Space on the Earth's surface now that
ALS also accompanies something like a 10
to 15% increase in crop productivity
which is also a major piece of data
right and that that's also a consequence
of carbon
dioxide increased carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and then I add to that other
data that I've seen that shows that by
long-term historical standards so over
periods of millions of years or tens of
millions of years the atmosphere of the
world is actually very devoid of carbon
dioxide and so although there's more
than there was 200 years ago there have
been periods of time where the planet
was a lot Greener and a lot Lusher where
there was way more carbon dioxide in the
air and that seemed to be pretty damn
good for plants so I look at all that
and I think okay so if there was no
political nonsense around this and we
were just analyzing the data as of today
why wouldn't we conclude that carbon
dioxide increase as a consequence of
fossil fuel consumption is a net good
yeah no this is this is uh an
interesting dialogue I think you laid it
out well uh I said in Joe mansion's
Senate hearing about two two and a half
years ago now it's important it was his
one of his big climate hearings faty
baral was there and a couple other folks
just four of us and I said it's
important to be both completely factual
and factually complete and factually
complete is hard Jord as you know we
none of us can do it it's just there's
too much now we can be completely
factual we can all have facts and
they're as well presented and known as
we can we're not trying to mislead
necessarily or maybe we are but but
factual completeness is difficult so
you're what you outlined there I let me
try to address on a couple levels as
succinctly as I can one is a geologist
um very true there have been levels of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere spere
that exceed today's by 20 times okay
78,000 parts per million not
okay when well back in what we call the
Mesozoic this is when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth uh the CR you know the
jur the Triassic Jurassic and the
Cretaceous periods in that
era plants were huge leaves on plants
were enormous animals were large
obviously there dinosaurs were around
there were small ones as well the Earth
was pretty healthy it was
warmer okay it was really truly What's
called the greenhouse time and I'm not
talking about we could talk about these
if you wish you know the the glacial
interglacial cycles that are about
100,000 years long that we deal with now
and minkovich described very well I'm
talking
about tens to hundreds of millions of
year Cycles Greenhouse Ice House
Greenhouse times when the Earth Earth
has been devoid of ice for the most part
and covered in ice as a snowball Earth
so the Mesozoic was one of those times
when it was high CO2 very warm and very
healthy now those creatures plants and
animals had had time to adapt to
that they had come out of one of the
largest extinctions on Earth at the end
of the Paleozoic at the End of perian
Time 70% of species are more went
extinct so this was a and we we Define
the time by that Extinction actually the
bi ology the paleontology defines that
not the other way around so they they
came into a new sense and
flourished and that ended and and by the
way time is such a hard concept let me
just give you a feeling for it this way
since we're talking about
dinosaurs often you'll see in a diarama
in some Museum a T-Rex having a battle
with a a Stegosaurus right well it turns
out stegosaurus had gone extinct long
before T-Rex came about in fact there's
more time between the stegosaurus and
the T-Rex than the T-Rex and us so
process that to give you a feel for time
okay and and so now a big impact event
happened at the end of the Cretaceous uh
big meteor impact in chickaloo in the
Mexican Yucatan
Peninsula and the Alvarez father son Duo
described that very well it put out an
aridium anomaly around the world that we
measure at the end of the Cretaceous and
could see and very I remember being grad
school at the University of Michigan at
that time the early ' 80s and they and
they came to speak and we were all so
smart we grad students we had t-shirts
made that showed a incoming meteor and
dinosaurs looking up saying oh you
know and and we thought a meteor killed
the dinosaurs right well that was right
you know it had the Fallout from that
and we didn't as grad students we didn't
know much did we in fact I didn't even
learn about plate tectonics an
undergraduate that's how far back I go
so we are always learning so the point
here is yes there have been long cycles
of changes in greenhouse gases CO2 being
one of those gases methane and others as
well if you come into the more nearer
term not to today yet but let's say the
last 5 million years we've seen about 50
glacial interglacial cycles and they're
pretty well documented okay in the last
million years 10 of those and what I
mean by that is over every 100,000 years
or so ice comes down from the north
Canada is completely under ice and parts
of the northern us Wisconsin Michigan
parts of New York City very well
documented under ice and I don't mean a
little ice a thousand to 2,000 ft up to
a mile of ice for 80,000 years and then
for about 20,000 years it
warms and the ice
recedes and we have an interglacial
period like the one we're living in now
and so during that interglacial period
and it started about 18,000 years ago we
see the ice melt which means sea level
starts to rise and and I'm talking about
rates like the movies you know the Gulf
of Mexico here in Texas was over 300
feet lower than it is today just 20,000
years ago and it started to rise 1 to
two cmet a year almost an inch a year
vertical this is very rapid rise and
flooded the coastal plane of Texas and
then about 7,000 years ago that leveled
up and it's been rising about 1 to 2
millimet a year ever since in the last
7,000 years so you've studied and seen
from the Stone Age to the Bronze Age to
Enlightenment you all the way through to
what we call the industrial revolution
of this past Century uh in that time
frame humans modern humans have evolved
in that last interglacial period
period and yes you are exactly right it
is one of the lowest CO2 periods in
Earth history and it's one of the
coolest periods in Earth history I'm not
talking about the actual interglacial
because it's warmer than it was 80,2
80,2 but overall that periodicity of
interglacial is one of the coolest
periods in Earth history that we are
enjoying today and a guy named
milankovich worked all this out while on
House of rest for 20 years on paper we
call them milankovich cycles and we
understand why it's a it's a combination
of the rotational orbit of the Earth
around the Sun and that varies so it
puts you closer and farther from the Sun
and then the the tilt of our Earth's
access and the rotation of the AIS
combined to form these 20 40 and 100,000
year Cycles embedded cycles and we see
this repeated over and over that's
driving modern climate today and it's
driving historical climate in what we
would consider the the recent past
geologically now superimpose on that
let's come into the today in the last
100 years
we have been burning fossil fuels more
than that actually we started with coal
of course in the 1800s it powered our
ships and
trains uh it replaced wood and hay the
carbon based fuels that we lived on for
thousands and thousands of years to make
our fires and to cook our food and to
power our vehicles oxen and horses hay
let's just call it hay you know stuff we
grew and then Along Comes coal and we
discover that hey nature did that it
made it really Compact and dense so it's
it's almost pure carbon now there are a
lot of things in it that aren't good
when you burn it for the air the actual
pollutants if you will socks knocks
Mercury particulate matter Etc that come
when you burn
coal so but that was a great fuel it
allowed us to do things we' never done
before including boil water make Steam
turn a turbine and run a generator and
make electricity and that changed the
world that's the event in time that
became that made us
modern societies at least as you said
those of us who are fortunate enough to
have that many still don't more don't
than do and we can talk all about that
made films about that so um so here we
are and we've been burning coal and then
a long so that's carbon and then Along
come hydrocarbons which are complex
carbon and hydrogen molecules complex
chains long chains and those burn even
better especially when we refine them
and make them into gasoline and Diesel
and jet fuel and that's great we can put
that into a vehicle now it's very dense
I'm happy to talk about why dense
matters but you get a lot of bang for
the buck you put 20 gallons of gasoline
in a tank and the impact of that in
energetic terms is remarkable okay I can
drive two three 400 miles on that tank
of gasoline and there's no nothing left
except CO2 emissions and you just fill
it up in three minutes and go do it
again it's
incredible okay
now it has the CO2 emissions component
to
it uh Along Comes methane CH4 for
hydrogen's for every carbon now methane
natural gas is what we call that and
there are other gases that are natural
Bane pentane whatever but methane is the
one we use a lot
of it's even more incredible the energy
density of methane is phenomenal you're
burning the hydrogen as well as the
carbon so we get heat from that it's a
very versal fuel I can make electricity
by burning methane boiling water steam
turbine generator I can put it directly
into vehicles in a compressed form
compressed natural gas I can use it as a
molecule to make things like Plastics
or ammonia for fertilizers you mentioned
Agriculture and those fertilizers again
Chang the world so that all is natural
gas uh plastics it's it's it's it's it's
one of the most versatile molecules we
have today and it will be around a very
long time produces less CO2 when you
burn it than than oil or coal but it
still produces CO2 and methane itself is
a greenhouse gas pretty potent one
doesn't last as long in the atmosphere
but it's pretty intense more intense
than CO2 in the atmosphere so these as
you said are very complicated but we've
moved out of this carbon economy into a
hydrocarbon economy and now we're truly
coming into a methane economy in that
economy it won't be a few more years
before we are using actually burning
more methane than coal in the world
globally not just modern societies but
as a world and that's the methane
economy it will have arrived and good
thing because it does so many positive
things for Humanity and human
flourishing and also Less in terms of
its environmental impact it doesn't have
the sulfur and the nitrogen than the
particulat good thing we've gone there
and then from methane we can make
hydrogen you know and and methane is the
best molecule to make hydrogen so you've
heard about a hydrogen economy your
listeners probably have hydrogen didn't
form naturally very much it is in places
but you got to make it you got to split
molecules either a water molecule H2O or
methane CH4 the two common ones that
takes energy less energy to split
methane than water so energetically it's
and economically it's better to use
methane as a source of hydrogen and will
be often the hydrogen economy at some in
some phase and you can use hydrogen for
a fuel and you can use it as an
electricity carrier and all sorts of
other things so this has been a really
nice natural transition that's been
happening driven by efficiency in
physics and those when when those happen
the economics are good and so the
markets adapt them and they grow and
that's what drives progress at the end
of the day that's a long narrative but
uh well there's three themes I want to
pick up on in that one is Cycles one is
time frame and one is progress sure we
can Define all those so so let me
continue with
my doubts let's say so if we're trying
see the first problem I have when I look
at the analysis of climate Doom
prediction is the problem that you
alluded to with regards to time frame
it's like well is there too much carbon
dioxide in the air and is that a danger
and the answer to that is well it
depends on when you compare it to and
that isn't just something you can brush
off to the side
because it's very if the starting point
you choose for your analysis of increase
or
decrease determines whether you see an
increase or decrease the gerain question
is well what starting point do you pick
and if the answer is well if you want to
demonstrate an increase for political
purposes you pick this starting point
and if you want to demonstrate a
decrease for political purposes you pick
this starting point and you don't have a
different criteria then the question
itself starts to become
incomprehensible because there's no such
thing as the question is there more
carbon dioxide now in the atmosphere
there's only the question is there more
compared to then and then is arbitrary
so I have no idea as a data scientist
how to solve that problem especially in
the light of the other things we
discussed like you said well the planet
is cooler than it has
been according to many historical
comparisons and more people die from
cold than Heat by a lot and so if you're
measure for what constitutes relevance
is effect on humans cool isn't to be
preferred to warm now there's obviously
extremes over which that isn't true at
all but as a rule of thumb the mere fact
that things are getting warmer isn't in
in of itself an indication of
catastrophe and Nei let me clarify too
on the cool part just so nobody
goes it was colder in the glacial period
for 80,000 years we're in a warm now but
in this in this one to five million
glacial interg glacial the whole package
if you will is cooler than much of Earth
history in the past in fact most of
Earth history in the past just to
clarify on that okay okay so so let me
add another wrinkle and tell me what you
think about this so when I first started
to study the sorts of things that we're
describing now um I was also curious
about the relationship between economic
development and environmental
Consciousness let's say that would be
attitudes and actions that are
associated with some concern about the
medium to long-term viability of the
environment and one of the things I
discovered very quickly which I think is
just an economic truism as far as I can
tell is that if you're so damn
poverty-stricken that your fundamental
concern is whether or not you're going
to have lunch for your children then
you're the probability that you're going
to spend a second thinking about the
medium to long-term viability of the
general environment is zero and so one
of the things you see reliably in
economic analysis is that if you can get
people up above $5,000 per year in GDP
production then they start to take a
medium to long-term view of
environmental sustainability and we
could Define sustainability perhaps as
something like their concern that the
planetory resources that they
hypothetically enjoy now are likely to
be there for their children their
grandchildren and perhaps even their
great-grandchildren so the time the time
frame starts to expand and so the rule
is something like with increased luxury
let's say or even enough food which
isn't exactly a luxury your time frame
of analysis expands and if you are
actually concerned about transforming
human beings into a species that
optimized its medium to long-term
commitment ments it looked to me like
there's nothing you could do that would
be more effective in that aim than
making sure that the bottom two billion
people aren't scrabbling around in the
dirt so desperately that they're willing
to burn tomorrow to ensure survival
today and then that there's a corollary
to that which is okay that means that
absolute privation is perhaps the
fundamental environmental concern if
this if this psychology of long-term
view is correct
and the fastest way to make poor people
rich or to get the hell out of their way
while they're trying to do it themselves
is to provide inexpensive energy which
because there's no in my sense of the
world there's no difference between
energy cost and wealth since energy is
work and work does everything that's
productive by definition if you lower
the cost of energy you lower the cost of
work and that makes people Rich so so I
would like you to tell me if you think
there's anything wrong with that
reasoning and then maybe we could also
have a discussion about progress on the
energy front what would it mean to okay
so let's do that yeah when we made our
first featur link documentary film on
energy called switch we filmed that in
2009 10 and post and 11 released it in
2012 and we went to 11 countries and
showed you each form of energy where it
was best in the world so we weren't
trying to make something look bad or
good we absolutely did the tradeoffs of
the pros and cons of each form in that
film however and it got picked up by
academic campuses and it's still shown
around 50 countries kind of as the First
Energy quote transition film we show we
weren't really transitioning so
energy is Modern Life there's zero doubt
about it turns out energy is all life
even the poorest Among Us need energy to
survive a few years went by and I said
to our director hey we kind of left out
Harry Lynch by the way brilliant
filmmaker we left out more than half the
world those who don't have these things
so we met we we made a second
featurelength film we filmed in 18 and
19 and post released it right at the
beginning of Co and 20 and that was on
energy poverty we went to six different
countries and we looked at the
circumstances in which people are living
in Ethiopia and Kenia and Nepal and
Vietnam and Colombia different
continents and and again some of the
positive stories around that Jordan uh
that you are describing but some other
real challenges as well what happens
when you don't have energy and you can't
get above that
$5,000 personal wealth what's the name
of that film it's called switch on
switch on okay so there's switch and
switch on yes yeah and it was a very
powerful film a very different style I'm
your on screen guide and and we take you
in and spend time in these different
areas and what you
see and and it came to light on us is
you
can't Aid is interesting you people take
aid and intentions are always good and
here here's some Aid to go do this thing
it turns out that thing be it a pump for
water a solar panel for a little bit of
electricity maybe a Light Bulb
Etc um it doesn't work unless the
community wants it they themselves have
asked for it and they will then take it
into the cultural situation in which
they will benefit from it and we saw
this over and over and over again it
becomes something that is sustainable it
survives it becomes a virtuous cycle of
growth I'll give you some a few quick
examples um you know a a a an induction
cooktop in Nepal selling them on the
Street Markets now they're very
expensive but it changes cooking indoors
with wood and the and we take you into
the SEI Memorial Hospital there and we
watch kids and mothers die you know more
die every year from breathing indoor
particulates by cooking indoors and Co
killed in 2021 3 million a year it's
just it's nuts and um another example is
hair salons in Bangladesh where the
women when they first got electricity
they used it for hair salons and hair
salons who would have thought well
culturally it's a safe place for women
to gather they share stories hair is is
a piece of culture the money they get
they invest back in the community at
three times the men and so all of a
sudden we have a virtuous cycle we take
you to Kenya and look at pumps for water
to grow agriculture Farmer John so his
backyard is now growing crops at more
than he needs so he can sell them into
the marketplace and now that creates an
economy a micro economy around which
growth begins to happen his choice is
need culturally not what we go tell
people to do and we the rich World why
say we call it what you wish you know
I've heard Global North not my favorite
term I've heard whatever you want to
call it but those who have colonialists
yes those who have more okay and and so
yes energy is fundamentally vital for
that and affordable energy uh and then
moving into reliable energy and then
eventually I don't like the word clean
it's kind of meaningless to me but
energy that has lower environmental
impacts but you're exactly right I'm not
going to worry about that environmental
impact if I'm trying to eat or my kids
aren't in a
school etc etc I'm going to worry about
basically you know go back to maof you
know my hierarchy of need I have to have
these fundamental things first in order
just to survive and everything else
becomes a luxury that I'm not going to
indulge in so
that's what we see we we the world needs
to come out of energy poverty it needs
to come out of economic poverty so that
we can all begin to there will always be
disparity in wealth but we can all begin
to function at basic what we would
consider basic human levels now and
that's why we made that film and that's
why I'm so passionate about this
dialogue I I absolutely think that
global leaders all of them every single
time Jordan energy security Trump's
climate security every single time look
at the action not the words look at the
action look what Germany has done look
what China is doing look what we've done
even in Canada where Mr Trudeau has some
pretty you know hey words but look what
you do you don't sacrifice your energy
security or at least you haven't now
we're starting to see not so far not so
far and we're seeing circumstances even
in the US now in California
and in New York and other places where
they're starting to get toward the edge
of sacrificing energy
security and wow get ready as that
starts to happen we've already seen it
happen in Western Europe we could talk
all about the countries that are doing
that well let's well let's talk well
let's do that that so so we could do two
things in parallel here so one would be
we we touched on the idea of progress
and so we have a working definition of
progress that's kind of risen out of the
convers ation and so one of the things
we could say is that if our goal is the
alleviation of misery and the
sustainable alleviation of misery then
one pathway towards that is to provide
lowcost energy to the ABS to those in
absolute
privation working on the hypothesis that
first of all that's obviously a good
thing to do if you think that uncessary
suffering is you know is is something to
be dealt with but also if you're
fundamental concern is sustainability
even over human flourishing which I
think is a mistake but anyways even if
it is the data that indicate that people
who have a certain degree of security
can take a longer term view seems
crystal clear so to me it's a mystery
why this is actually an issue you know
because once you know that you think
well obviously then you make a hierarchy
of energy sources and you find out
what's inexpensive and you calculate the
trade offs in relationship to even
potentially carbon dioxide production
but there's sort of a pathway and I'd
like your opinion on that so you know
dung Isn't So Good Wood is better than
dung coal is better than wood natural
gas is better than coal you know better
it's denser but you can move along that
yeah okay so so what so how do you see
progression in the marketplace with
regards to the alleviation of absolute
privation what's the logical steps to
undertake globally and and then how is
that being violated let's say in places
like Germany sure yeah and not to be too
sanguin about it but in the end physics
wins yeah dense wins now what do I mean
by dense U the bang for the buck on a
per unit weight or per unit volume or
even a per unit area that's called
surface power density um where do you
get more energy for your buck if you
will and so if I can do more I used
gasoline is an example of dense but let
me throw a curveball my my tank of
gasoline will drive me 300 miles okay
well the energy equivalent of one little
uranium pellet that I stuff into a fuel
rod in a nuclear reactor one pellet
centimeter High half a centimeter wide
the energy equivalent would drive me
from New York to Los Angeles and back to
Dallas one pellet that's dense energy
compared to gasoline which is very dense
compared to
lots of other things that aren't dense
the Sun the wind Hydro biofuels things
that take a lot of land to do so physics
wins in the end and we need to allow
physics to win I am not a person who
thinks that it's either the economy or
the environment Jordan I just don't
believe that I don't think that the data
lead is there I think we in this sense
can have both but we can't have all of
both okay and there's the tradeoff space
if I want 100% zero CO2 emissions well I
don't get energy security and I don't
get Economic Security I get very little
of that okay I got to bring that why
would you want well why would you want
100% this is the thing I don't quite get
I mean let's assume that there are
people who are willing to make that
tradeoff their their goal is like Net
Zero carbon dioxide admission or even
reversing it it's like okay your point
is we're going to pay a major price for
that and the Wii isn't going to be you
and me the Wii is going to be the
world's poor wherever they happen to be
and they're going to get walloped like
devastated by it what's the old line
when the work when the when the uh when
the aristocrats catch a cold the working
class dies of pneumonia well it's always
the case if if 5% of the world's
population is barely hovering on the
edge of viability ility and you double
their energy costs they all die yeah it
turns out this is not good so it turns
out 60% of us live in some level of
energy poverty today I'm going to say
that again 60% 5 billion out of 8.2 and
and and I say some level they're not in
abject energy poverty and economic
poverty not the bottom
billion that's come up after Co
unfortunately we were doing great but
it's that next level where energy is not
secure to them
it comes and goes unpredictably the
electricity is maybe on an hour or two a
day my fuel price is volatile and I
don't have it sometimes so we don't
understand these things these are
so-called electrified energized
economies but it's not what you and I
have nothing close right okay so this is
which is something that works all the
time all the time
affordably yes yes and that's very hard
to achieve but the 99% absolutely is is
is is what we strive for so I think
you've kind of brought us back around to
the question I never answered about
Greening so I'll just chime in on that
yes the Earth is Greening you can see it
from space uh CO2 is a is a food you
described it well we have to be a little
cautious there some of that growth is
not plants that are the kind that we
would expect in those
environments and they're not very
diverse so you get a lot of aggressive
growth
sometimes of Exotics things that have
come in including in the reefs the Great
Barrier Reef has growth but it's a few
species not the healthy diversity of
species that we see so we got to be a
little cautious this is back to the
completely factual and factually
complete on describing what that looks
like and whether it's kind of a Healthy
Growth if you will a very important
Point um but
nonetheless yes the world isn't baking
in the
Sierra the Sahara Desert hasn't gone you
know crazy in that sense either um but I
I I come back to kind of that that
trajectory of energy then
fortunately and
fortunately we we can address the
emissions with dense
energy okay it's maybe we're lucky maybe
it's not a coincidence but methane
CH4 uh
hydrogen um nuclear uranium and thorium
being used as a heat source to boil
water make Steam turn a turbine run a
generator that's fion the fusion side of
the equation which is getting closer I
used to smile but it's getting closer
and I'm not a nuclear physicist those
are things that have zero to no
emissions and they're very dense and the
Technologies are ever
better and so there's a solution staring
Us in the face here it's not necessarily
the one that climate scientists and
climate well just the climate
impassioned um not because a lot of
climate scientists are wonderfully deep
thinkers and great scientists they leave
the realm a little bit as they start to
talk about energy just like I leave my
realm if I get into deep climate
modeling so we have to allow the
scientific space for those who have the
most expertise to help us move forward
in in entic terms to address emissions
and human flourishing and it can be done
well we we should make a stronger
statement than that there is no bloody
way we're going to move to environmental
sustainability on the backs of the poor
because they won't have it if we produce
enough economic
Havoc which we could easily do then
we'll produce a deterioration back to
very short-term thinking and will
produce an environmental nightmare so it
isn't can we have human flourishing or
zero impact on the planet it's that if
we put the poor under too much stress
which is first of all is an absolutely
unconscionable thing for rich people to
be doing but if it does there's going to
be a kickback the likes of which we can
hardly imagine yeah let them eat cake
well guess who ate
cake right off with or zoo animals right
right cuz if you make a you know if you
take a given country and you destroy the
economy you're going to destroy all the
animal
because as soon as people get hungry
enough they're going to eat everything
so we have to manage human beings so to
speak we we have to allow human beings
to step up the energy density ladder so
that they can address their absolute
privation so they can take a longer term
View and there's no environmental
solution absent of that as far as I can
tell right there's a there's an
interesting we've talked about energy
the economy and the environment there's
another e that's really important here
one of efficiency and let me let me just
briefly describe that and how I think
about efficiency in the United States we
use about a 100 quadrillion BTUs of
energy every year 100 quads what does
that mean to anybody nothing that's
interestingly enough it's about a
quadrillion BTU is about the same as an
exle term physicist love that means
nothing it's about the same as as a
trillion cubic feet of natural gas maybe
we're getting a little closer into the
space people start to understand it's a
lot of energy
100 quads it come primary energy comes
into our system we use it for
residential commercial industrial and
transportation reasons that's how we use
energy heat and cool things and move
ourselves around okay the 100 quads
comes in Jordan guess what only onethird
of that does useful
work twoth thirds of that is wasted
mostly is heat and other things it
doesn't do anything useful so we have a
lot of low hanging
fruit in that space even if we could go
to 50% does useful work think of that
that adds another 17 quads of energy
without adding any more Primary in so
it's there's an incredible opportunity
here as the world begins to lift itself
from poverty and the modern world
continues to stay healthy to do
more with less I'm not changing my
lifestyle and those who need to change
your lifestyle can but we can all do
more with less we can become a lot more
efficient and how we use energy and
that's how we ended our very first film
when you end a film it's with the last
thing you want them to remember was on
just personal efficiency things it's not
it's not rocket science these are simple
things we can all do and I'm not saying
you know go to austerity measures and
turn off your heating in the winter time
not at
all quite the opposite just simple
things we can all do and so that's a
very important piece of this overall
equation and I think the opportunity to
waste less as the world begins to
modernize is there it's ripe for the
taking that's one of the things we the
modern societies can can transport to
evolving developing and developed and
and and emerging economies is is
efficiency as they gain energy yeah well
it it makes sense to me that as the
developing countries develop they're
going to start with technologies that to
some degree we have superseded right so
you see this for example with China's
hyper Reliance on cheap coal and some of
which is provided by the Australia that
won't burn coal themselves now I know
coal produces a fair bit of particulate
matter but it doesn't really matter
where the carbon dioxide is produced
because it turns out that we all share
the same atmosphere so the Chinese and
the Indians in particular and those are
the most populous countries and the same
thing is going to happen in Nigeria at
some point because it's going to be the
world's most populous country by the
year 2100 they're going to step up the
energy density La ladder and it it would
make a certain amount of sense that the
developed countries I mean China can
obviously do this to some degree by
themselves are going to turn
increasingly to sources of extremely
high density like nuclear sources but
then I see these weird inversions where
countries like Germany and States like
California have decided Well the next
right thing to do in the progression
towards a sustainable economy is to shut
down the nuclear
reactors and so and then in well in
Germany they burn H they burn legite
coal which is high particulate high
carbon dioxide as a consequence at least
a partial consequence of shutting down
their nuclear reactors and so when I see
that I think well what the hell is going
on like there is no standpoint from
which that makes sense so no there is
what are the impediments what do you
think like what's the proper pathway
forward in your estimation and what are
the impediments to that at the moment
boy there's a lot here to unpack I'll
try to be brief we have lignite in Texas
we call it black dirt you know it's it's
hardly coal it's not anthracite by any
means or other forms of coal so Germany
is has that they increased their coal
production 133% when they set down their
nuclear reactors and climate scientists
were a gast and they should be that was
crazy okay there's a cultural component
to Germany's fear or
adversion to nuclear power I don't fully
understand it France on the other hand
about the same size Etc has a nuclear
Fleet they needed it so they didn't have
options so they built their nuclear
Fleet it doesn't make sense you can't
make um logical sense of that that's a
cultural human thing in Germany and
other parts of the world they're going
to change you're starting to see it
maybe they'll evolve it with small Maja
reactors which they'll think is
different but it's not it's the same
technology it's fishion whether they're
you know light water reactors or sodium
cool whatever pick your favorite it's
still Vision um but that's fine you know
if that's what it takes to help mitigate
some of that fear great um you see China
building they're the China and Russia
are building 75% of the world's reactor
nuclear reactors today just those two
countries and they have a lot more on
the books China gets it now they're also
growing everything else rapidly and this
is where that completely factual fact
complete comes back in you will hear
completely factual China is the leader
in solar and wind in the world they have
more than any other country true you
scale it all down and it's still a
trivial part of their total energy
consumption it's just a few percent of
the power alone electricity alone and
electricity is only 20 to 25% of total
energy so this is the scale challenge
Jordan China has to have at all and they
are going toward dents uh
China's energy alone China's annual
energy consumption alone just that
country is more than all the electricity
consumed in the world
combined all the electricity in the
world okay so that's a scale challenge
we just have to start to understand the
scale you said it very well India and
China combined are one out of every
three people on the planet today one out
of three
now getting a little population
demography um China's birth rates are
some fertility rates are some of the
lowest in the world at 1.2 India is now
at 2.1 which is the replacement rate
India has come down to 2.1 who knew I
didn't there's a great right demographer
shock a shock yes and a UT Austin guy
and what's been happening since the last
30 years if picture this graph I'm a
data guy you know the bottom is GDP per
capita and this axis is fertility rates
okay I was looking at those the other
day it's incredible every large country
in the world over a million people over
since in the last 30 years the fertility
rates are just plummeting all of them
and they're moving toward wealth they're
not wealthy they're moving toward wealth
and so this is a remarkable Trend
underpinned by energy now there are a
lot of people very concerned about this
including China we
this gets philosophical we Define growth
as good if you're not growing you're
dying what's China's not growing in
population anymore and they don't they
don't bring people in like we do in our
countries you so they're rolled they're
seeing their population do this and how
are they going to continue to
grow and how's the world going to grow
what we see in those studies is around
2080 that's not very far away the world
Peaks at 10 billion people from our 8.2
today and it doesn't it doesn't Plateau
it plummets back down right it plummets
well so well so you've added another
interesting and counterproductive
observation so even well well even if
even if you were concerned about human
impact yes let's say if that was your
primary concern was human impact on the
biosphere no matter how that was
measured
your logical steps forward would be to
make the poor Rich as fast as possible
not least because that is by far the
most effective method of population
control we've ever invented as you
pointed out it's absolutely staggering
in some countries yeah step one yes well
and and and so now I would say as you've
already intimated that the fact that
fertility rates have declined so
precipitously is going to become a
problem in and of itself but we can
leave that aside we can especially leave
leave that aside if we're concerned
about human impact on the planet because
we would recognize that as a net good so
even if you're one of these people who
you know derived from the club of Rome
think there are far too many people on
the planet the obvious cure for that is
to make everybody Rich because they stop
having babies so it's another reason
that I can't like I can't understand the
pervasive nature of the insistence for
example that we have to
de-industrialized to serve the planet's
interests most appropriately and then we
can look at
practical examples like Germany where
this is starting to be implemented and
all the consequences appear to be
negative including the fact so Germany
and I think I have these figures about
right energy is now five times as
expensive in Germany as it needs to be
but it's also far dirtier it's more
unreliable and it's more dependent on
dictators to provide like who in whose
interest even hypothetical is any of
that it isn't serving the green agenda
in the least quite the contrary so well
maybe it's in the interest of you use
the word dictators autocrats yeah maybe
well short term okay it keeps me elected
yeah well it seems to it seems to be
keeping people elected in people like
places like Germany of course all the
farmers are having a short circuit in
Germany at the moment and that didn't go
so well for the Dutch authorities
obviously yellow vests in France you had
the truckers in Canada I mean the people
are starting to speak and they're
starting to speak wisely people I think
you and I both believe that the markets
are very wise and very smart uh you know
they get it people we understand the
markets understand these things it may
not be quite as quick as some would like
but your fundamental question or and I
think you're not confused because I
don't think you're confused about too
much personally but your fundamental
question is a very real one how can we
how can we make energy more expensive
we're starting to De industrialize we're
seeing companies and industries leave
we're increasing the cost and the burden
on the poorest amongst us that's
regressive in economic terms it doesn't
help the environment because the rich
can actually afford to buy these things
from other places import energy and
again another quick fact in the US only
11 States produce more energy than they
consume 39 States consume more than they
produce and buy a lot and the big ones
New York and California they're
importing their energy well that's great
as long as you can but ask Germany how
that went when the Russian gas stopped
it didn't go well and so we have to
start to um conflate these things in
what I lovingly call the radical middle
and have for a couple decades we got to
put these in there and there's nothing
there's nothing glamorous about the
radical middle it's brutal there's
there's data and there's compromise and
I'm not always right
but it's where the big challenges lie
and that middle is between energy the
economy and the environment and how do
those play together so that we can solve
these things for real let our young
people have the complexity of these
they're very smart but if we keep
telling it's binary clean and dirty good
bad believer dener they're not going to
have the tools they're they're just
going to think they're evil and they're
good it's it's a it's a kind of a
bizarre story and most of people and I
speak to a lot of people when they hear
these things they come strongly to
saying I want to be in there I didn't
get it hadn't learned all that hadn't
heard I want to be part of that complex
equation and help to address these
things for real so what you're doing
matters a lot communicating well some of
what's some of what's happening with
well so imagine the attraction of that
binary system is twofold okay so the
first is
that it's something it's very
straightforward and simple
industrialization has Environmental
costs therefore industrialization is the
problem okay so once you've identified
that you don't have to think anymore you
just have to be against
industrialization so that solves a lot
of technical problems and that reduces
entropy it reduces complexity at least
in the short term but then there's an
additional psychological component
that's unbelievably powerful and I think
the radicals particularly on the
environmental left have been very good
at falling prey and capitalizing falling
prey to and capitalizing on this so the
developmental psychologist Shan P
pointed out that um in a fairly large
subset of adolescents um those who are
maybe higher along further along the
cognitive distribution so a little bit
of intellectual horsepower to spare they
go through what he described as a messic
phase in late adolescent late
adolescence and what that would mean
anthropologically is that there's going
to be a subset of bright kids kids who
they've they removed themselves from
dependency on their parents they've
socialized themselves into the peer
group but now they're looking to take
their place in the broader world
conceptually and practically and there's
a philosophical element to that and the
philosophical element and this is the
Messianic part is that they want to do
they want to act ethically and do well
at the highest level of striving and so
what we're offering them in our culture
is the chance to play Hero on the
environmental preservation
front and so that satisfies that need
which is a real need but it also does it
in a very false way because it and this
is one of its attractions just like you
can oversimplify the industrialization
issue industrialization is bad and all
human impact on the planet is to be
issued you can simplify the moral issue
which is now if you're on the side of
the planet you're good and your moral
duty has been done now that's absurd but
the thing is is that people let's say
like you who are promoting the radical
middle haven't elucidated a vision
that's as compelling on the
psychological side with regards to the
Fulfillment of that deep metaphysical
need as the environmentalists who offer
young people the opportunity to be
planetary saviors just by waving around
a plard and this is a real problem and
it it speaks to problems like
the attitude in Germany that's
anti-nuclear you know your sense is well
that's irrational and look at France
from whom the Germans import energy by
the way who've managed a nuclear
transition brilliantly and have energy
to spare and at a low cost like there's
no logical reason there but these
so-called illogical reasons they're real
reasons and they're real impediments and
you know one of the things I do believe
that people found attractive about your
talk and about the sort of things that
Bjorn lomberg are doing is that a new
sort of standard is being waved which is
something like well here's a better
moral Vision how about we make everybody
who's dirt poor Rich as fast as we
possibly can and then we can have our
cake and eat it too we can serve the
poor which is like a classic left-wing
orientation and like I've been shocked I
literally I've been shocked to the
degree that the radical leftists will
sacrifice the poor to the planet cuz I
wondered when push came to shove because
there's two competing Tendencies there
right there's the green environmental
tendency fair enough but there's the
well everything should be done in
service of the poor tendency and what
we've seen time and again in the UK and
Germany and Canada well and around the
world is that if we had to choose
between hypothetically serving the
planet and helping the poor we'll pick
serving the planet in the Nano second
and to hell with the poor and that's
that's not a vision that a lot of people
find particularly attractive I think you
are offering an alternative to that yeah
yeah and I'll be extreme in this
statement but almost the elites have
flipped what used to be Republicans in
the US used to be sort of elite if you
will and now they're working I think
more with that next class than than the
Democrats are the Elite it it's it's
almost flipped in a strange way and
again that's an extreme characterization
within those bodies we have everyone
okay the whole Spectrum but I I think
you can have your cake and eat it too as
long as you don't try to eat the whole
cake right right well that's the Net
Zero problem yes it's like no zero like
no net zero that's the wrong measure
like you can you can put that in your
mind and you can remember it in a second
it's a nice cliche but zero it's like
you're not thinking when it's zero right
well you know it turns out when that c
when that report came out of the iea a
couple summers ago I speak to a lot of
boards and sit on several um I got a
call from a chair a CEO and he said you
got to come talk to my board this week
and so I did I read it and it was
incredible the assumptions that went
into that this was preg glasow okay cop
I think it was 26 in glasow
um they set up a framework in which
there were a lot of crazy assum but the
craziest amongst them Jordan was this
that the energy consumption in the
world would start to go down two years
later which is
today down aggregate energy consumption
in the world down in order to achieve
that Net Zero and there were a lot of
other things and I I looked at that and
I I made the figures and I showed this
wedge between you know GDP and human
population before we Peak in 2080 Etc
that's that's that's literally
impossible okay it w it won't go down
now we can help lower the per capita
consumption and therefore start to help
things nobody challenged it it became a
road map for cop 26 and I was with Dan
Jurgen he was on our PBS show and he
said Scott you have to write this up so
I put out a little piece called the road
to glasgow's paved with bad assumptions
you know and and it it was and but we
used it as a road map I think this is
the single one of the single
more um destructive almost too strong of
a word but destructive constructs that
we're dealing with now is this concept
of Net Zero now admittedly net means if
you can capture some out of the air and
atmosphere that's part of net so I could
still emit as long as I'm offsetting by
some level of capture Net Zero not
absolute zero important distinction but
we're not Net Zero is is kind of this
weird Target that I think a lot of
people have rallied around we've got to
begin to think beyond that and
recognize you know use an analogy I want
to run a marathon you know I'm 64 years
old I want to run it in four hours which
I I'll never do but that's my goal let's
say I run it in four and a half hours
but I finish
it I achieved something big you know it
wasn't four hours it was four and a half
hours maybe net 40 is okay or net 50 or
net 30 you know we've done we've brought
down but we haven't imploded the
economic health and well-being of not
just the poorest among us but the whole
global economy which is starting to
happen because if we do
that the environment's going to get
crushed you know it's going to be
irrelevant so so so fast that look what
Germany did you can't even imagine it
it's not hypothetical anymore that
Germany consumed more coal they burned
more coal when they needed to and other
economies will do the same thing when
push comes to sub global leaders say it
again prioritize energy security over
climate security every time so we've got
to F so young people you ask a good
question how do you get them away from
just that we have to begin to think away
from a
b okay it's not it's not an AB
linear like that it's actually ABC you
can't jump from a to c just to the
environment there's energy there's the
economy and there's the environment and
it flows that way healthy energy
underpins healthy economies healthy
economies invest in the environment so
the more we can accelerate that the
better and and young people working in
there if you could have two goals lift
the world up from poverty isn't that
amazing and begin to clean up the
environment not perfectly but begin to
clean up the environment ently
intelligently well and well the other
thing too on the environment front like
it's also not obvious to me at all that
the most compelling environmental
problem is associated with carbon
dioxide so well so for example one of my
bug bears for a few decades has been the
state of the world's Fisheries the O
Oceanic management because of all the
stupid things we've done in the last 100
years and we've done many things that
weren't stupid but of all the stupid
things we've done decimating the ocean
fisheries has to rank up there very
highly and like the estimates that I've
read that I believe to be reasonable and
I'm certainly no extremist in this
matter is that we've depleted like 99%
of the accessible world's accessible
fish stocks and given that that's a
renewable resource that can actually
bounce back pretty damn quickly given
how many eggs fish lay it can bounce
back quickly if you leave it the hell
alone it's like another part of the
problem with this unidirectional
obsession with climate apart from its
sketchy base in in five different ways
is that there are a lot of other
environmental problems that we could be
addressing that they just get no
attention at all you and I grew up
learning about water and land and air
that was the environment we were
protecting clean water and an abundant
water uh tough problem uh clean soils
and land less land use is good you know
more with less and clean air not talking
atmosphere air local Air so the land the
air and the water are three of the four
components of the environment and the
atmosphere is a fourth those are not
just interchangeable they're
interconnected so if I start to put for
example in place something that has no
emissions but consumes a lot of the
earth's land solar
farm okay a large wind farms I just d
drove through the Texas Panhandle
recently you can't do it without seeing
wind turbin doesn't consume all the land
but they're everywhere lowdensity forms
of energy use a lot of the of land to
collect energy so that it can get it
dense enough and abundant enough for us
to use I go beyond that and say to get
to those wind turbines which are
composits and copper and lots of other
precious resources es and solar panels
which have lots of metals in them and
and and other you know polysilicates uh
batteries to back them up extreme amount
of metals just the amount of Mining and
look I'm a geologist I don't mind
mining doesn't bug me because I know we
mine everything we don't grow but I can
also tell you the amount of mining that
it's going to take to produce enough
energy
collectors in that system is incredible
so we're talking about not just land but
water mining I've never I've asked
audiences every time I speak Jordan I
speak to about 20 30,000 people live a
year how many think mining is green and
never has a hand gone up never cuz it's
not you know we can make it better but
it's not green so when you start to
think about the Earth in that holistic
sense with climate being one component
of it this is another thing we have to
balance the tradeoffs between the land
the air water in the atmosphere and it's
messy it's not perfect we have to we
have to get away from this idea of
Nirvana per you know Perfection if we
could just get rid of CO2 in the
atmosphere no it won't go that way so so
one of the reasons that we so at this
art conference we had a lot of music and
and there there was a reason for that I
mean we wanted to make the conference
beautiful and we wanted to give people a
breather from purely semantic discussion
and but there's there's another reason
that's deeper than that and it has to do
with the meaning of Music per se you
know you talk about tradeoffs but
there's actually a there's a positive
way of of describing what you're getting
at with regard to tradeoffs so what you
see in music is a Harmony between
competing forces and the the beauty of
music is the balance of that cooperation
and competition across some span of time
right it's it's a melody of interweaving
patterns and you know that if you're
somewhere where things are going well
that there are many competing forces
that are harmoniously balanced and
there's an intrinsic Beauty to that and
when you talk about tradeoffs it's a
pess there's an implicit pessimism in it
that you know there's going to be costs
but there's another view that we tried
to put forward in the art conference
which is that if we get the balance
between the multi
multiple requirements for Life optimized
that there's an intrinsic Beauty in that
and that's the right Target and so it's
not exactly tradeoff it's not tradeoff
it's it's it's multi-dimensional
optimization now it's more complex as
you said because you can't because it's
multi-dimensional you can't say that if
we get to 100% on axis a we've now
established the kingdom of God it's like
well it's 70% on axis a and 6 5% on axis
B and but there is a genuine Harmony and
goal there yes and that's a see that's
the kind of higher order goal that
positively posited could be attractive
to the young people for example who
become hyper concerned morally about the
planet absolutely right and so I know
you're being hard-headed when you talk
about tradeoffs but but if you have a
family you're not trading off exactly
between the kids yeah well I I
definitely love one of my four kids
better than the other three I just don't
tell which
one right right exactly but I use I use
a I use a Turner diagram for this
concept and in a triangle diagram
everything has to sum it's 100% 100% on
one corner as I move away from that
corner I'm picking up components of the
other thing but everything sums to 100%
somewhere in there and the reality is in
the middle somewhere that radical middle
is a balance between the things we're
trying to do so let's not call a
tradeoff we're not giving up one we're
balancing them good word that you use
there very powerful harmonizing yeah so
you're you're your wavelength okay so
I'm going to take your music I Got
Musicians for kids but those are just
wavelengths in science and so those are
wavelengths of different amplitudes and
different
wavelengths and so the big Bas wave
comes in and the and the treble wave and
a loud and a and a soft but they can
sound beautiful together when that music
is made in that way we've talked about
the wavelengths of CO2 coming and going
of ice coming and going nature produces
a lot of things that have those embedded
Cycles or waves Jordan that's how
science of the earth works and we can
study and measure it just like music and
so finding that beautiful Harmony and by
the way the music was beautiful I stayed
on the brakes and filmed those musicians
they were just phenomenal um is is is
the goal is otherwise you end up with a
cacophony of sounds that are just
they're an irritant to to to hear right
when you truly don't get things right or
something is just Out Of Tune and you
can hear that pitch difference uh you
know it's like oh you know well we have
an instinct we have an instinct for that
balance right that harmonious balance
and it's also a good place maybe and
this is a good place to close this part
of the discussion this is also why it's
so important to rely on bottomup
information propagation of the sorts
that can be provided by markets it's
like so our our hypothesis is well what
we're aiming at now is a target that has
to be specified multi-dimensionally it
can't be reduced to Any Given Dimension
has to be specified multi-dimensionally
now that makes it complex so where is
that Target and one the first answer is
well we don't exactly know and the
second answer is well we can take hints
from bottomup markets because they're
the most intelligent computational
devices we have they're closest to the
reality of the environment because
they're made of millions of people going
about their business in direct contact
with their local environments and we can
allow those signals to propagate and in
that is some indication about what the
appropriate Harmony might be so we see
that Disturbed for example in Germany
because the farmers have decided that
the the dimensionality of the solution
is inappropriate in relationship to what
they need and they're throwing a Banner
into the works and that's and that's
inevitable and so well partly what we've
been trying to do with the with the ark
is to
specify a little bit more explicitly
what that multi-dimensional landscape
might be right and then to set that as a
Target that people could strive towards
morally now it's complicated so it's
difficult to package as a story but it
does seem to me that and there isn't
anything you said today I think that
contradicts this is there's no reason to
assume that we couldn't collectively set
our minds to the uration of absolute
privation through appropriate energy
provision in a manner that would
radically increase medium to long-term
sustainability of the whole project
right right I agree with that that's not
a pie in the sky notion no I published a
piece earlier this year which I titled
Net Zero
poverty right right right and and and
the editor changed the title as they do
but that's the concept is is to drive
without that nothing else will will work
Jordan nothing else Works nothing else
works we have to we have to strive for
that we the collective have to strive
for that and the and the most important
Dimension and we geoscientists
geologists deal with this all the time
not that I can truly understand it but
probably have St it more let's just say
that is the dimension of time and so we
plot all these things but that time
Dimension is so vital because if I'm
struggling to feed my family I don't
have 20 years I don't have a year I have
now and yes I can think in longer terms
because I'm
wealthy but it doesn't mean I'm going to
act in longer terms and we see this
propagated over and over it's not
intentional
hypocrisy but it's apparent hypocrisy
and what our leaders are saying and what
they themselves are
doing in their own personal lives and
people people pick up on this they say
look you don't tell me what to do if
you're not willing to do it in your own
life and and and so how do we
get the market the whole Market engaged
age and I have to believe that the Greta
tumberg of the world and she's in her
powerful voice could
help carry this story I use her as a as
a as a as a metaphor a simile for the
young people could carry this story of
poverty and environment together okay
the Dual challenge if you will so that I
gave a TED Talk a couple years ago on
this the Dual Challenge and and and
talked a lot about how do we we carry
that and so I said to them somewhere in
the middle of that talk and this was the
Shocker moment as we were looking at
solar panels wind turbin and batteries
1100 students in a room and I
said I explained where those come from
and I said there's no renewable energy
don't hate me but there's no renewable
energy there's nothing there's nothing
renewable about mining
manufacturing collecting wearing out and
dumping and doing that over and over
again that's not a renewable process
and that they digested and a lot of L
long line afterwards but this is this is
this complexity a little bit that
they're ready to go for you know I've
got my kids range from 33 to 23 they're
ready they're brilliant you know they're
ready to tackle this Challenge and I
know the young people in the world are
as well if they can get U structured
around this so at switch the not
for-profit I started many years ago we
do something called a case
competition it's universities around the
world teams of four competing on a Case
competition on energy poverty and they
they're multi- disciplinary teams and
they have three weeks to try to lift
real countries out of energy poverty and
this year we gave them a pair of
countries to compare and contrast and
it's hard they keep wanting their each
one has a volunteer Mentor very powerful
and they present in real there's cash
prizes you know online presentations and
they they're so empowered but it's so
hard and they're like there's no
answer
correct there's a suite of possibilities
As you move out into that time future
that time Dimension but you can
constrain that in real ways that don't
that don't fly off into sort of physics
never Neverland if you will and they
come away empowered I would love we've
done this four years in a row several
thousand students let's energize them to
build these this core c PS core of young
people and your network is incredible to
begin to take that and run with it and
let old guys like us just just invest in
them and say run run run go go go how
can we help you to address these two
issues that would be powerful well
that's an excellent place to stop and
pretty much dead on time I think I'll
probably name this Net Zero poverty and
we'll do energy and environment the Dual
challenge that seems like a good yeah
yeah yeah and so well thank you very
much for talking to me today and for and
to everyone who's listening and watching
and for walking through these problems
it's so interesting a because to me when
I started to study these problems more
deeply all that it did was make me much
more radically optimistic because what I
discovered was oh I see so the solution
to energy and environmental
sustainability is the eradication of
absolute poverty well that's a good deal
like like who why would we be upset
about that that's such You couldn't
possibly imagine a more
positive solution to that Suite of
problems no
more heart-rending
privation and the propagation of a much
more long-term view of sustainability
around the world well that's a damn good
deal so well so I think your talk at ARC
you know went some ways and all the work
you've done has gone some ways to making
that a more real possibility and we'll
hope that that's the direction that
prevails as we move forward in this new
year Jordan it's been a privilege to be
on with you and thanks for the
invitation and thanks for all the work
you do yeah my pleasure my pleasure so
thank you to everybody watching and
listening and it's this is the first
podcast I've done in the new year so
happy New Year to all of you and thank
you to the dailywire plus crew for
making this possible I'm going to
continue this conversation on on the
dailywire plus side I'm going to talk a
little bit about um the origin of these
ideas I think that's what we'll delve
into and also where you see them going
in the future practically and how that
might be facilitated by this Arc
Enterprise and so for those of you who
are inclined join us on the daily we
plus side and um otherwise thank you
very much for your time and attention
today and thanks again sir very
interesting thanks
[Music]